Hello Again!
As you can hear,
I have not been fired by Letitia YET.
Let's have a look at some more community questions
that were either interesting or caused
some confusion within the answers.
So, for the first question, opinions were
divided: most of you actually think the
gradients of individual pixels show you something
useful (gradients regarding the output, that is).
What was meant here was simple:
Take for example a classifier that
gets an image and predicts a cat.
We now want to know: what
does the network look at?
For that, we simply get the gradient of each
individual pixel regarding the output, that is,
we see how much the output changes if we
slightly change a single pixel's value.
In theory, that may sound great, but
the information of a single pixel can be
somewhat deceiving - a simple argument against
something like that, at least in our opinion,
would be for example what adversarial attacks do.
There, you also look at a
pixel and see how you want
to change those pixels to have the
network predict a different class.
As a result, a really tiny disturbances can
already cause a totally different classification.
Simple pixel information seems to be
very unstable and not super reliable,
at least for many cases where I
personally have looked at that.
And there are actual papers that look at that too
- these examples here compute simple gradients
for each pixel regarding the output class that
has been produced, showing what's "important"
to produce this label for the image.
As you can see, this is super noisy
and often pixels on the object itself
are not even the most important ones,
like for example for the camera, the lens is
actually not important in this visualization.
A more refined solution is what they suggest
instead: compute the gradient not just for
one single pixel and its current color, but
integrate over the gradient of differently
blended versions of the image, for example
blending from black to the actual image.
And that then gets rid of some of the noise
and produces something that is more stable.
For example if we now look at the camera again,
we can now see that the lens actually seems to
help in the classification and
seems to be important for that.
If you want to know more about this,
you can find the integrated gradients
paper [https://arxiv.org/abs/1703.01365] and a
great distill article with more on that topic
[https://distill.pub/2020/attribution-baselines/]
in the description box below
[Interpretability 2: Concepts]
Similar to the last question, this one
also aims at better understanding what a neural
network actually does internally internally.
Consider for example a
classifier for images again.
We then look at our examples and split them in
two different groups by some characteristics,
and we do that splitting in the
deeper layers of the network.
For example, we split the dataset in images
with, and without water in the background.
Now, the normal of that hyperplane that
splits our data in the latent space,
is now aactually a direction in which we can move
an image representation, for example in this case,
to make it more or less "watery", in the
sense of what the network actually perceives.
And we can now use that to measure how important
that water is for a classification result:
We can compute the gradient of this direction
with respect to the output of the network.
Through that we see how the output of the
classifier changes if we move a sample in
the latent space along that hyperplane normal,
that is, how the output changes if we make an
image more or less watery. For example for the
ship class, we should see that making an image
more or less watery, should have an impact on
the classifier output, as I've been told that
ships usually are in water and thus, that's
a good cue to be used for the class label.
And coming back to the initial question: We
can also measure that way how important for
example a text label is in an image
for the resulting classification.
This is great to for example see if your
network just "cheats" on a task by abusing some
(for example) text labels that
have been hard-coded in the image.
A paper that looks at all of that in depth, called
TCAV, and that tries to measure that, quantify
that in some way, is linked below. It's a really
interesting and well written paper that gives
you a lot of new ways to view at what networks
internally and how we can put that in numbers.
[VQ-VAE: Without Quantisation]
We then had two questions about
Vector-Quantized Variational Autoencoders.
While those don't sound that exciting,
remember that they enable for
a great things like DALL-E.
In principle, a VQ-VAE is an Autoencoder
where the latent space is quantized,
that is, you encode some input, then round the
latent codes to the closest codebook value,
and then decode that discretized value,
to obtain the original input again.
This learned discrete representation then works
a bit better for some tasks because you can
more easily use, for example, transformers
on it that are built for discrete inputs.
Also, some things in the real world
like words or hand-written digits
are just discrete, so it comes more naturally to
express them through a discrete representation.
Now, this codebook that we are using
to discretize the encoder output
is also learned during training, which
means that for the loss function,
we now have the original reconstruction loss,
just as for a normal boring autoencoder,
and two parts the regularize the latent space
to better fit the values of the codebook,
while also moving the used codebook
items closer to the samples.
If we now just drop that vector quantization part,
namely, the two extra losses that adapt the
codebook to the latent codes and the latent
codes to the codebook, all that's left
is the autoencoder reconstruction loss.
And without that discretization - well,
we then just have a plain old autoencoder.
And that also means that we no longer get
the properties similar to a variational
autoencoder (VAE), namely, a nice and
tidy latent through this codebook.
[VQ-VAE: With infinite sized codebook]
Similar to that question before, let's look
at what happens if we make the
codebook of a VQ-VAE infinitely large.
For the loss function, remember
that we take our encoded image
and then quantize that to the nearest
codebook values before we decode that.
Now there are two possible interpretations of the
question that largely depend on
the initial distribution of the,
let's assume 1-dimensional here, codebook
and the initial distribution of the latent:
First of all, if we say that an
infinite codebook would actually
mean a codebook with all possible codewords in it,
then we would have all the possible numbers
our encoder could come up with in there.
If that's the case, then both these losses
would become zero - if every latent part is
actually in the codebook, then we would
not need to move our codebook closer to
the encoder output OR move the output
of the encoder closer to the codebook.
And as a result, these terms are always zero, and
we just have a regular, old boring Autoencoder.
And that is was what I was actually
going for with this question.
But as the comments pointed out, that's
not the only possibilie interpretation.
For the other possible interpretation,
let's say that our infinite codebook
has a certain distribution, for
example having numbers from [-1, 1].
If our encoder, luckily, falls
into that range and we stay there,
great, we're just not going to have any
quantization related losses that are non-zero.
BUT if we produce an encoding that gets out
of that range, things get a little bit hairy.
If we'd have a value outside of that range, say,
smaller than -1, we move that value that comes
out of the encoder towards -1 while moving the
codebook entry with -1 towards that actual value.
However, we JUST move that one entry on the
boundary there, not touching any other values
in the codebook for now, as the codebook is only
adapted for the codewords that are actually used.
So now, we have a codebook that has some values
being quantized and some not being quantized. And
over the iterations, that will spread out, and
we'd for example end with something like this:
We have a core dense region between [-1, 1] where
quantization doesn't do anything because all the
values are in the codebook, and then there's
a region where we just regularly discretize.
So, this will eventually act like a regular
autoencoder for anything inside [-1, 1] and like a
regular VQ-VAE outside of that, which is somewhat
weird. Can you come up with a useful scenario for
that? Or do you even think we overlooked something
and we get an entirely different behavior? If so,
hit us up in the comments, because for now,
that seems more like a pile of rubbish to me.
[Disentangling with Pearson's]
Next up is a FANTASTIC question (yay,
thank you for that!).
We wanted to know whether one could use Pearson's
correlation coefficient to disentangle
the latent space of a neural network.
Well, disentangling basically means that
we want the latent of our neural network
to be nice and tidy: For example that
of an autoencoder on handwritten digits
is actually split into different characteristics,
like having one variable in the latent express
thickness and the other variable in the latent
expressing the number which is actually displayed.
Sadly, an unregularized latent space isn't that
cleaned up, and these characteristics are all
over the place. Maybe we want a distribution
where the latent is nicely split into one
variable having thickness and the other one
containing the digits, all nice and tidy.
But in truth, they're actually
looking like this instead,
with one variable having both
characteristics in them a little bit.
And that's just one possible way,
but this is something we do not actually
want for disentangled representations.
What's important is that these variables
are somewhat correlated in latent space now,
meaning that for example when we have
some information about the X axis,
we also get you some information on the Y axis
as well. If we're in this part on the X axis,
we know that we can only be
in this part of the Y axis.
Throwing Pearson's correlation coefficient on
the loss to enforce that from X, we can no longer
linearly extrapolate Y would somewhat prevent that
- but there are a whole bunch of issues with that.
We would just prevent a LINEAR correlation
that Pearson's correlation coefficient
measures, but nothing more. Anything
non-linear is not really caught by that.
And as these networks are sneaky,
they can just choose to "hide" these
properties in a non-linear fashion to circumvent
that, still being all messy and entangled.
[Point clouds]
And lastly, let's get to the juicy
geometry. Regarding pointclouds, there's a whole
bunch of reasons why they're messy to work with.
From these answers, the number of points
is clearly not a problem - one could say
that 128 points are actually all you need
to see that this is a chair. Opposing an
MNIST image where you have 28-by-28 pixels
and you'd already end up with 784 values.
However, permutation invariance is a thing though
- you don't have a canonical order of those points
like you would have for images or voxels, that
are essentially just grids with values in them.
To explain one of the ideas to get around that
-- that was already mentioned in the comments,
thank your for that -- let's go quickly
over the idea of PointNet - you find
the link to the well-written
paper in the description box.
The key idea is simple: put the points through a
function that is permutation invariant as well.
For example, if we take the maximum of a, b and
c, that is the same as the maximum of b, c and a.
So, maximum is a symmetric function.
And that's what they're essentially
using to become permutation invariant:
put all points through such a function.
What then they do, is they take every point
individually, apply a shared neural network
to it to bloat it up to, say to 1000 dimensions,
and then apply max pooling across every dimension,
ending up with 1000 maximum values that form
your embedding of the input point cloud.
So, by using this symmetric max function, we
got rid of the permutation sensitivity, while
also not caring how many points we actually put in
here, because we always end up with 1000 values.
And this resulting embedding you can then process
to for example classify with it whether
the input model is a plane or a chair.
Aside from permutation invariance, you
have a bunch of other issues though:
no properly defined convolution operation, varying
densities you'd get from a laser scanner, etc.
And lots of fun with geometry! And that's
just the issues you have with pointclouds,
triangle meshes are even worse if you ask me ...!
So, thank you for staying with me
untill the end - if YOU have any
cool suggestions for community questions,
just send them and we will credit you!
Hope to see you again!